- How have you been entertaining yourself
to get through this time?
What have you been doing?
- I watch Reality TV.
- Oh, I love that.
Wait, what's your favorite?
- "Below Deck."
- "Below Deck," okay.
- All franchises.
Every single franchise.
I have slipped into the DMs
of certain crew members
and who are now my friends.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that.
- I'm like an uber weirdo fan.
And so I watched that.
Started getting into "90 Day Fiance"
and all those franchises.
Very interesting social study.
(Kelly laughs)
- My friends are obsessed with that one.
Well, I actually--
- It's an interesting one.
- I actually heard about one of those.
So I have a little surprise for you.
So, can we see that?
- Christina, how you doing?
Captain Lee here from "Below Deck."
I just want to say thank
you for being such a big fan
and I want to encourage you
to stay strong and remember
that a good sailor never learned
a damn thing in calm seas.
So I know you're gonna navigate
these waters just fine.
And if you decide you
wanna set sail again,
you just let me know
'cause we have a deck chair
with your name written all over it.
All right.
And if you'd like to DM me
sometime and just chat, I'm here.
All right.
Take care kiddo.
Bye-bye.
- Aww, I love my Lee.
Oh my God, I'm tears in my eyes.
I'm not kidding.
I literally have tears in
my eyes, I love him so much.
Kate had him send me a
video about, I don't know,
six, eight months ago and
it was just very sweet.
But that's like, ah.
Oh, Captain Lee, my angel.
- I love you.
- God of the sea.